mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour bonjour bonjour comment ça va
vous allez bien tous oui ça se passe
bien
bon pour mieux marquer en bas en
commentaire j'ai envie de savoir comment
vous allez alors aujourd'hui c'est un
endroit peu exceptionnel parce que on va
ouvrir sa là dedans vous avez le tout
dernier produit de one place 8 t
normalement c'est son nom on va sourit
alors à la différence des autres fois où
j'avais des informations en amont ce
qu'on appelle un prêt briffaud les
journalistes sont informés journaliste
influenceurs sont informés via la sépaq
a donc on va vraiment partis à la
découverte à la monture de ce produit
voir ce qu'il en est directement
ensemble et ça c'est génial parce qu'il
ya tout juste d'être annoncé par une
pelouse on compare regarder ce produit
voir à quoi ressemble voir s'il est
intéressant le découvrir et puis bien
évidemment je compte sur vous pour dire
ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire mais juste avant qu'on
souffle ça va être un grand moment
eh bien je compte sur vous pour venir
vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà le cas
comme ça vous serez informés de toute
l'actu télé nouveauté les tests et plus
on parle surtout de vous et de votre vie
numérique pour vous abonner c'est très
simple pour vous ayez un compte google
bien évidemment vous cliquez sur le
petit bouton rouge en dessous vous
actionnez la cloche comme ça vous serez
notifié n'est qu'une prochaine vidéo
arrivera et ça c'est très cool ses
devoirs yes ultra stop
arnaud singh ultra stop or nothing ultra
stoxx arm holdings ok on est d'accord là
dessus alors là effectivement voyons se
parle du média quitte c'est vraiment le
ski fournir tout cas pour les médias
alors pour se lever normalement ça va se
donner comme ça ça j'aime beaucoup
vraiment le packaging à chaque fois qui
est fait pour le média qui tu es même le
packaging en règle générale c'est
toujours bien bien léché de la part
douanes place hello hello and places
très très cool bien vu de la part de one
love est là donc on va voir le
smartphone là ces moments où le produit
se dévoile je vous dis je ne le connais
pas wang losc et on ouvre là ok alors
attendre avant de voir le smartphone on
va regarder ce qui est ici normalement
là toujours là l'invitation later ça
c'est vraiment un grand classique chez
eux 1 ça marche avec le petit mot du
fondateur
fred alors déjà en attaque on est
vraiment un ami merci pitt u13 au volant
je lirai le petit mot plus tard en tout
cas c'est cool non du congrès mon petit
tiroir de cartes sim qui est juste là
j'ai un petit quizz start guide pour
tout savoir sur le smartphone capteur
d'empreintes digitales à pied on a des
infos ici donc sur le das tête 0.94
watts par kilogramme co
un bull 24 watts par kilogramme est
membre 2,47 watts par kilogramme ou une
planche d'autocollants wyplosz 8 et bien
vu très malin safety guide
ok bon si vous voulez faire un peu de
lecture vous pouvez donc tout ça et là
dedans c'est parfait maintenant nous ce
qui nous intéresse c'est ça c'est le
smartphone en lui-même
olala nom de dieu monsieur gros que tu
es mauvais alors ça déjà je peux vous le
dire
j'adore la couleur mais j'aime bien
cette espèce de allez on est d'entre eux
du bleu et du vert c'est vachement sympa
le module photo on voit qu'ici j'ai donc
3 4 je dors un double flash donc ça
c'est intéressant on va regarder ce
aussi dans quelques instants sur le côté
et bien comme d'habitude sur une pelouse
je peux changer entre le mode sonnerie
le mode silencieux ou alors carrément
tout ça c'est bien le bouton pour
l'allumer pour l'éteindre
j'ai un haut parleur ici ma recharge en
usb ses tiroirs de cartes sim qui se
situe à le micro qui est juste là de
l'autre côté je vais avoir et bien le
bouton de volume tout simplement sur le
dessus une micro pour la réduction de
bruit quand j'ai ma petite caméra qui se
loge juste là je pas si vous la voyez
aussi vous la devinez ça y est le
smartphone est ouvert regarder ça c'est
très très très très sympa on va
retrouver comme je vous le disais ici
votre petite caméra qui est situé à
l'avant on va regarder les specs dans
quelques instants parce que pour
l'instant je ne les connais pas par
coeur on a un écran qui plaît par contre
on n'a pas d'écran incurvé ici sur ce
modèle mais bon ça fait la sphère des
bords qui sont très fins en haut et en
bas sur les côtés ça se tient très très
bien la prise en main est bien le
smartphone est assez long donc la prise
en main est très très bonne par contre
effectivement c'est un smartphone qu'il
faudra venir utiliser à demain vous
pouvez soit utiliser toutes vos
applications la suite l'une de l'autre
ou alors utiliser votre tiroir
d'applications vous pouvez activer ou
désactiver si vous le souhaitez on
tourne là dessus bien évidemment sur
oxygen os c'est la version 11 alors moi
ici j'ai une mise à jour à faire que je
ferais tout à l'heure justement pour
pouvoir l'installer il ya deux gigas
donc on va prendre le temps
tranquillement de le faire donc ça s'est
très très bien taux de rafraîchissement
de 120 hertz donc on les a toujours sur
la même chose depuis le début d'année
120 hertz ou 60 hertz avec un switch
intelligent qui va se faire donc ça
s'est très très bien mode lecture les
couleurs vives on a pas mal de
paramétrage et ça une fois de plus c'est
très bien et c'est très très bien
construit du côté de chez swann plus
haut niveau de leurs horizons ça c'est
vraiment bien pour attendez moi je suis
curieux de voir déjà l'audio on va aller
faire un tour du côté de youtube
alors je découvre en direct on se met
comme ça on parlera là j'ai donc bien
moins on parle ainsi de tout alors qu'on
dit le toujours sur des haut-parleurs
stéréo fait voir
ah ça marche bien ça marche très très
très bien hop là en plein écran alors
vous avez effectivement cette petite
partie là vous l'aimez vous l'aimez pas
bon les dans les codes de 2020 donc
c'est pas extrêmement dérangeant le son
est bien assez équilibré ça fonctionne
bon de ce côté-là ça c'est très très
cool capteur d'empreintes digitales pour
le déverrouiller rapidement j'appuie ça
des virus est très rapide très réactif
ça c'est cool
- écoutez moi j'aime bien on est dans ce
que fait ou en place donc ça c'est pour
le côté esthétique du smartphone
maintenant on va regarder un peu les
specs ensemble on va se pencher
justement ça ce qui nous donne c'est le
reviews 'guide' je le sais bien que
l'accent le truc à savoir c'est qu'à
chaque fois qu'on ne peut se lance un
nouveau produit est bien il envoie cinq
médias c'est ce qu'on appellerait guide
pour venir vous aider à donner les
nouveautés high à connaître les points
forts de du nouveau smartphone ans donc
là on a plein d'infos à l'intérieur moi
ce que je vous propose c'est que comme
je ne connais pas ce smartphone est bien
qu'on le découvre ensemble on va
regarder quelles sont les grosses
nouveautés
et puis comme ça ont réagi à chaud je
pense que c'est ce qu'elle me of life
est assez sympa la première chose qu'on
nous montre autant de l'intérieur
saisirait les points forts qu'on va
avoir un écran de 120 hertz peyrefitte
assez cool de l'avam charge rapide 65 la
performance les quatre caméras
le design ok on vient de le voir oxygène
os 11 ça marche les spécifications
accompagnera temps il nous paraît très
très rapidement pour aller vraiment
l'essentiel puisqu'on se regardera tout
lors du test et bien effectivement l'on
nous parle de l'écran fluide amoled 120
hertz choqué jusque là y'a rien de bien
d'un coup on marche on sait ce que c'est
on a déjà parlé du taux de
rafraîchissement 120 air ça vous apporte
plus de fluidité qui on a un écran full
hd plus ça marche qui est plus fin en et
luminosité qui va jusqu à 1110 donc ça
c'est très très cool donc
potentiellement il est très lumineux une
gamme de couleurs dci p3 ça c'est
parfait dont je pense toute façon on va
avoir un écran d' extrêmement bonne
qualité on est sûr de la molette donc on
est sur une dalle qui est fabriqué par
samsung donc on connaît la qualité et je
puis vous assurer qu'à mon avis ça sera
très très cool un gros focus sur les
couleurs ça marche ensuite la recharge
mais effectivement de la recharge 65
watts et ça ça va très très très vite
pour venir charger votre smartphone
qu'est ce qui nous donne comme un fou
rire effectivement d'une batterie de
4500 millan perreur y en a une charge
complète en 39 minutes côté performances
on tourne sera sa dragonne 865 ok c'est
pas mal je me serais presque attendu ici
1 865 plus qu' un poil plus rapide mais
on est vraiment sur un des derniers soc
de qualcomm et qui allaient plus rapide
actuellement donc c'est un traître
bien bien évidemment un smartphone 5g
sens on doute on peut aller jusqu'à 12
igad ram et 256 go de stockage en ef s 3
points tandis que c'est ce qui marche
très très bien
je pense que la ram c'est la lpddr2 5 si
vous vous y connaissez
et bien sachez que c'est une des techno
drames les plus rapides de toute façon
chez wang place on a toujours des
smartphones qui marche très très bien et
je m'inquiète absolument pas là dessus
le modem c'est lui que 55 de qualcomm 5g
on va passer très rapidement là dessus
parce que c'est assez technique ça pas
forcément bien vous intéresser parce que
la 5g si vous êtes en france tout de
suite
eh bien il pas encore démocratisée wifi
si ça c'est très très très cool
toutes les infos effectivement sur lui
ai fait ce 3.0 mais bon voilà c'est
vraiment technique on passe là dessus
les technologies de refroidissement pour
pouvoir venir jouer parce que oui
effectivement c'est aussi un smartphone
et pour le gaming quatre caméras alors
ça ça nous intéresse vraiment qu'est ce
qu'on nous propose un ultra grand-angle
s'écoule une caméra principale je vois
ici 1,48 mégapixels ok 14 26 mm ok ça
marche de la macro et le monochrome
alors là il ya un truc est toujours un
peu rigolo c'est de se dire qu'ici j'ai
pas de télé objectifs ça veut dire que
ma caméra principale me servira de
téléobjectifs en gros je veux dire
zoomer dans mon image 48 mégapixels pour
arriver à une image je pense 12
mégapixels bon j'aurais bien aimé qu'à
la place peut-être d'un monochrome ou
d'un d'une macro on vienne me mettre un
téléobjectif qui je pense en tout cas
sur les usages aujourd'hui serait
beaucoup plus pertinents dont c'est le
choix douanes pleuvent on verra bien
évidemment lors du test
ok donc là on nous parle effectivement
on a un ultra grand angle à 2 123 degrés
ok bon sur le principe pourquoi pas en
vendre à l'état tout à l'heure un vidéo
shooting stabilité au quai lors la vidéo
est vraiment mis en avant cette fin
d'année oxygène nous reste une super
expérience a franchement chez android
on a vraiment avoir un nuage de samsung
et oxygène airways qui sont pour moi les
deux gros qui se détache qui sont super
après si google vous êtes vraiment sur
l'android purée ça marche très très bien
mais si vous allez dans les expériences
jeu direct au niveau des constructeurs
oxygène os one plus one way samsung
series meilleur tie-break from tech
ça c'est important je pense que nous
emmène sur les haines mode voyez c'est
ça l'idée qu'on coupe son smartphone et
qu'on peut plus venir vous embêter off
hors appels d'urgence que vous avez un
souci
bon pourquoi pas à les infos alors en a
effectivement un verre corning gorilla
glass je sais pas quelle version ses 188
g c'est vrai qu'il n'est pas très très
lourd l'adreno 150 au niveau du gpu bon
je vous passe ou ça à l'envoyer à je me
suis trompé
erreur de ma part tant c'est très
intéressant on n'est pas sûr de la lpp
5 on descend de la lpddr2 4x ça c'est
marrant est ce qu'une petite coupe
franche là dedans au niveau du budget je
sais pas intéressant très intéressant
bon là 4x marche bien mais savait que
l'a5 va aller un peu plus vite ça c'est
très rigolo ce qu'ils ont fait là dessus
alors fait qu'il mena du bluetooth 5.0
il faut le savoir codec apt-x ap et x
hdl des as et assas et ça marche très
très bien on a dû annoncer ça ça marche
aussi très très bien l'écran alors bon
petit écran de smartphone ici allez hop
là je pose le doigt
jeanne écran de 6 55 pouces ok why not
résolution de 2400 par 1080 pixels à 402
pixels par pouce ça marche le ratio sera
douté parce qu'elle est quand même très
très long c'est du 29e caméra alors les
caméras se désintéresse veille sur la
caméra principale qu'on va voir on s'est
de tout temps ici on est sur le saunier
1586 bon 48 mégapixels ça ou qui ont
connu de la stabilisation optique de
stabilisation électronique une ouverture
f 1.7 notre ensuite l'avoir
ultra-grand-angle qui est planqué là on
voit surtout qu'on a 16 mégapixels qu'on
ouvre à f 2.3 champ de vision je voulais
donner la macro cdu 5 mégapixels je suis
pas persuadé de la qualité on va
regarder vraiment la macro 1 avec une
distance de 3 cm pour venir shooter moi
je suis jamais vraiment bien bien fan de
ça on va regarder le capteur monochrome
pour avoir quelques effets de 2
mégapixels je sais pas moi j'aurais pas
fait ce choix-là genre vraiment bien été
l'objectif mais après c'est toujours une
question de coût bien évidemment on peut
bien filmé chant 4k à 60 images par
secondes ça marche on va à l'essentiel
un caméra de celle fitr est de 16
mégapixels pardon scellier mix 471
stabilisation électronique mais pas
optique ici ce qui n'est pas surprenant
de nature de f 2.4 alors sur le papier
le smartphone je le trouve plutôt
intéressant maintenant je manque de
certaines informations pour vous donner
un avis global à un instant t en tout
cas je n'ai pas le prix et pas la date
de dispo à la date de dispo j'imagine
que ça ne saurait tarder faites-en le
tarif c'est vraiment est ce qu'il va
faire l'intérêt de ce produit ou pas en
fait parce que s'ils un tarif qui est
vraiment intéressant et très bien
positionné il se peut que je vous
conseille d'aller dessus maintenant
quand je vois ce que nous propose l'aide
ce one plust on n'a pas le 8 165 plus de
pâles comme ça peut être un petit peu
embêtant parce qu'on est sur le même
socle qu'on avait sur la série 8 de ce
début d'année
on a les techno drame qui fonctionne on
n'a pas de l'ipad et dire ça qu'on va
les payer à 4x bon voilà ça se tient pas
grand chose pourquoi pas c'est pas
vraiment ça qui va creuser l'écart sur
l' usage un peu standard ont un
smartphone qui est adapté pour rim qui a
adapté pour le visent
un âge qui adapté pour les réseaux
sociaux avec un écran de 120 hertz donc
on a un truc qui marche très très bien
maintenant moi je suis un petit peu un
petit peu en dessous et une fois de plus
je sais pas s'il va sortir un modèle pro
parce que je n'ai pas d'infos si un
modèle pro qui nous propose un capteur
principal qui nous propose un
téléobjectif et qui nous propose en plus
un ultra grand-angle je pense que là
dessus je signerai je trouvais ça
intéressant maintenant sur ce smartphone
est une fois de plus en fonction du
tarif qui va être annoncé une formation
que je n'ai pas tout de suite et bien
bon il manque quelque chose il me manque
ce téléobjectif et ça aujourd'hui pour
moi acheter un smartphone flagship
killer ou pas quand on est dans le haut
de gamme
on est dans le haut de gamme là dessus
de toute façon il faut se le dire c'est
à dire que j'ai un smartphone où il me
manque un des éléments essentiels en
photo c'est le téléobjectif et je trouve
ça un peu dommage
on va voir le positionnement tarifaire
je vous donnerai tout mon retour dans ma
vidéo test d'ici quelques jours laissez
moi le temps de tester j'aurai les uns
fois ce mois-là tarifs et compagnie donc
je pourrais vous dire s'il est vraiment
intéressant parce que ce qui va venir le
positionner ses nerfs de la guerre c'est
quoi c'est l'argent tout simplement donc
en tout cas moi comme ça je voulais tout
de suite j'aime beaucoup la couleur je
la trouve bien
il a scellé le jeune format écoulée
compagne clara jeu très rapide donc
sociale très très très très gros point
positif on reste dans ce que ses fans
pleurent mais ce qui m'a vraiment
déterminée tout l'intérêt d'acheter ce
produit c'est effectivement le résultat
du test mais son tarif par rapport à ce
qu'on retrouve sur l'ensemble du marché
à la concurrence
voilà donc pour cette première
découverte de ce smartphone ensemble le
one love suit et dites moi vous ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
d'un point de vue purement design
esthétique est ce qu'il vous plaît
ou alors pas du tout et qu'est ce que
vous en pensez par rapport à ses
caractéristiques techniques pour moi
c'est un smartphone qui peut destiné à
tout un chacun a des gens qui cherchent
un smartphone à ses produits pour aller
jouer parce que franchement ce qu'il
faut à l'intérieur comme à des personnes
qui veulent un smartphone pour aller sur
les réseaux sociaux pour naviguer sur
internet et ce avec beaucoup de fluidité
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire quant à nous on se
retrouve extrêmement rapidement pour
continuer à parler de tête même si en ce
moment et j'en suis sincèrement désolé
j'ai un peu moins de temps je voulais
dire sur la route la dure depuis trois
semaines avec amazon pour une série
d'émissions que j'anime j'ai encore
trois semaines un mois de tournage donc
assez peu de temps pour mettre des
vidéos sur la chaîne néanmoins ces
canettes ont rendez-vous pour certaines
pour certains rendez-vous justement
voilà on voulait pas trop je vous aime
et je donne rendez vous extrêmement
rapidement ou des bisous et beaucoup
d'amour a très vite cha cha ou
où
fb